president ramaphosa thank you so much
for speaking to dw news after the aueu
summit here in brussels
talking about this trips waiver you have
come to brussels with the intention of
persuading the europeans to change their
vision
and to release the ip on the
intellectual property on vaccines so
that they can be produced in africa
germany is one of the countries that is
most reluctant to do so how much of your
anger towards the europeans is directed
towards germany and what does this mean
for africa that this trips waiver isn't
coming into place
well on the trip's waiver issue it's not
so much anger that is directed against
anyone or in particular germany
i had a wonderful meeting with the new
chancellor
mr scholz and we had a good exchange on
the issue of
the
ip waiver
and i explained to him what
is driving us
to
put forward the arguments that we are
putting forward
and i said in our view when we are in a
pandemic like this
what
will get us out of the pandemic should
be regarded as a public good it should
not be seen as a
profiteering type of
instrument or product it should be
what should be readily available
and i think that message got through to
him
and he started arguing that you know
even the originators don't necessarily
want to make money out of it i said well
then
we've got two
uh
objectives that that can be put to to
good use for us to reach agreement
and obviously they want the originators
want to make
to do more and more research
and i said there are ways in which we
can we can meet that objective by
reaching a consensus
on the ip as it stands so that
countries that are able to utilize that
ip
and south africa being one of them
should be able to utilize the ip to
manufacture more
and more vaccines and i did say that
we we don't want to be receiving crumbs
from anybody's table
we we don't just want to fill and finish
where we get the drug substance from
somewhere fill it and then put it on the
market we want to be able to manufacture
the drug substance ourselves and that is
where the real heart of the ib and the
ip
argument comes in
and i said
that should be fairly straightforward
and then again i argued
that
this is not for ever type of provision
we want it for a set period
and so that we're able to get over this
vaccine
so i think that message got through and
it is for that reason that
we've it's now been felt that
it should be there should be a two
process uh negotiation at the
commissions
and thereafter should then be transposed
to the wto itself
with the active participation of the
director general of the wto by the way
dr ngozi the director general is very
keen
that a solution should be found
that a compromise should be found
because this is the type of pandemic
that requires
both sides to get together and find
agreement
now what happened at the end of this
summit is that there's six hubs that are
going to be created in africa one of
them
in south africa it's sort of been
accepted but as a positive step
but as you mentioned this is sort of a
fundamental
issue between africa and europe this
idea of the relationship and this summit
was about trying to
change the relationship
does this issue to you highlight the
real fundamental problems in the
relationship between africa and europe
i would say the reluctance
of
europe for instance to agree
to reach an agreement on the trip's
waiver
it's what weakens the relationship
an agreement on the trip's waiver would
strengthen the relationship would
consolidate it
and i did say as much in the meeting
that
if we are not able to reach agreement on
this
it would be seen that this was a failure
however a proposal was put on the table
to
to try and find another avenue of of
addressing this matter and
i look forward to seeing whether a
solution will be found
because if we're not able to find a
solution on this despite everything else
that is being done in the way of
making vaccines available to africa
uh the the the hubs that are being set
up
it will mean that we have not really
been able to find each other on a matter
of life and death
a key matter
where we should be embracing one another
and finding one another the rest of the
other things can happen
but if they find people dead
what is the use
of all that
so we need then to do things in tandem
and all at the same time and be able to
demonstrate that our partnership the
value of our partnership
is important
do you approve of
france's withdrawal from mali or are you
worried that this is going to have a
major security effect in africa
well
this has been discussed it it obviously
the withdrawal is going to have a
negative effect
but at the same time
france is motivated by a whole range of
issues including i think their own
domestic issues
so one needs to be considerate of that
but
the security issue in the sahel
is a major major problem and
the the assistance and the support
of
other countries such as france has been
of great help
and
when we come to security matters
there's a need to cooperate thank you so
much president ronaldo